es un alivio para muchos mientras la
mayor central nuclear de europa vuelve a
conectarse a la red eléctrica de ucrania
la central de sap orilla estuvo
desconectada durante varias horas
después de los incendios provocados por
los bombardeos cercanos y que dañaron
una línea energética
afortunadamente los trabajadores de
nuestro servicio de emergencias que
trabajaban en los territorios ocupados
han podido venir hasta hoy estaban en la
central nuclear lograron apagar todos
los incendios que se iniciaron en la
línea de transmisión de energía los
técnicos lograron restablecer el
suministro eléctrico la planta está
actualmente ocupada por las fuerzas
rusas y kiev y moscú se han culpado
mutuamente de los continuos bombardeos
cerca de la instalación el jueves por la
noche el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski anunció que la región se había
librado por poco de un desastre nuclear
los generadores diésel se pusieron en
marcha de inmediato para suministrar
electricidad a la central tras el apagón
el oiea y otras organizaciones
internacionales deben actuar con mayor
rapidez porque cada minuto que los
militares rusos permanecen en el lugar
conlleva al riesgo de un desastre
nuclear mundial
un equipo del organismo internacional de
energía atómica de la onu espera visitar
la planta la próxima semana pero el jefe
de la agencia ha manifestado que las
negociaciones sobre el acceso siguen
siendo complicadas
mientras tanto los residente de sap
orilla dicen que se están preparando
para lo peor
claro que tengo miedo todo el mundo
tiene miedo no sabemos qué va a pasar
qué es lo que nos espera en el próximo
minuto en el próximo segundo neto nos
compramos máscaras y yoduro de potasio
con la esperanza que nos ayude por si
acaso naciones unidas- presiona para que
se establezca una zona desmilitarizada
alrededor de la central antes de la
guerra la planta de esa polilla
suministraban más del 20 por ciento de
electricidad del país